Hey everyone! We are back and we are ...
going to have a look at how and what we produce relates ...
to the costs we incur. Let's jump into it.
Let's first start by recalling how much content you ...
created when you added workers to your content ...
creation process. With no labor,
nothing was produced.
When you added one person, your total content increased ...
to 2 and your marginal product was 2.
Adding a second person increased your total product ...
to 5 and marginal product by 3.
Adding a third person increased your total product ...
to 9 and marginal product by 4.
At this point, your marginal product peaked.
Adding a fourth person increased your total product ...
to 12 and marginal product by 3.
Here, diminishing marginal returns sets in.
We can only get so much out of the fixed inputs we have.
To change this, we'd have to add more capital ...
to our content production process.
Adding a fifth person increased your total product ...
to 14 and marginal product by 2.
Adding a sixth person increased your total product ...
to 15 and marginal product by 1.
Adding a seventh person did not change your total product ...
and your marginal product is 0.
It's not a good idea to add this worker,
as they create no additional content for your business.
Next up, let's talk costs.
First, let's address the fixed costs ...
associated with running your business.
These are costs that do not change as output changes.
Remember that computer you bought.
Let's say you took out a loan to buy it.
You can create as much content on it as you want and ...
that loan payment does not change.
Here, we have $1,000 as our fixed ...
cost. As we add more labor and ...
produce more, our fixed costs do not ...
change. You'll also notice that you ...
have to pay $1,000 even if you producing nothing.
That's because this is a cost you've incurred and it doesn't ...
matter if you produce or not.
Next up variable costs. These are costs that do ...
change as production changes.
As you add more workers to your content creation process ...
you incur additional costs. Let's look at the first person ...
you hire. It will cost us $800 to hire this ...
person on a weekly basis and they help increase output or content by 2.
The next person we hire adds an additional $700 per week,
and adds 3 additional types of content per week for a total ...
of 5. Let's go ahead and add in ...
the rest of the workers and you'll see that our variable ...
costs continue to grow because we are adding more ...
to the content production process.
We go from $600 with the third worker,
All the way to $1,200 for the last worker we hire.
Notice that our variable cost first decrease then increase.
Why does this happen? Several reasons.
It could be labor market conditions,
or it could be the marginal product that each worker ...
produces is tied to their wage rate.
Take a look at the demand for resources chapter for ...
more explanations. Before we get to our last cost,
there's one other type of cost called a mixed cost.
This combines fixed and variable costs.
For example, if you do not use electricity,
you still have to pay a base rate.
The base rate is the fixed cost,
and the usage becomes the variable cost.
Okay! We now have our total costs ...
of producing content. Total cost is the summation ...
of fixed and variable costs. Notice that with no workers,
I still have total costs equal to $1,000.
That means I still have expenses even if I don't ...
employ anyone or produce anything.
My total costs also follow the same path as my variable ...
costs. That's because of how ...
production and costs are tied to one another.
Here, we have marginal costs,
which are the change in total costs over the change in ...
output. Notice that my marginal costs ...
start high and then fall to their lowest point with the ...
third worker. Now,
adding the fourth worker increases my marginal costs.
The fifth, sixth and seventh workers do ...
as well. This is all because of how ...
diminishing returns kicks in to the production process.
Adding more workers to a fixed amount of capital ...
reduces how much is produced.
But also adding more workers increases your cost of doing ...
business. Hence,
as you increase your production and labor,
your output diminishes and your costs rise.
Let's look at our cost curves.
We have our fixed, variable and total cost curves displayed.
First, notice the fixed cost ...
curve—the red line—is horizontal at $1,000.
This is because our costs do not change as our output changes.
Next, noticed the variable cost ...
curve starts at $0. This is because if we don't ...
employ anyone, then we don't have variable ...
costs. The shape of the variable ...
cost curve also picks up the mechanics of diminishing ...
returns. Up to 9 units being produces,
our costs grow slowly. After 9 units produced,
our costs grow with each additional unit produced.
Lastly, the total cost curve—the ...
green line—starts at the fixed cost line then follows the ...
same path as the variable cost curve.
First, we have to pay a cost even if ...
nothing is produced. Second,
total cost is the combination of fixed and variable costs,
so the distance between total and variable cost is just fixed cost.
Let's finish with a look a how production and costs relate.
Here we've overlayed our production function on the ...
cost curve graph.
Notice up to 9 units of content created,
our costs grow slowly and our production grows fast.
This is because we've only added a few workers,
so our costs are low, but they are making efficient ...
use out of the resources available to them.
As we continue to expand, our costs grow more,
but our output grows slowly. Eventually,
we get to the point where production flatlines and costs ...
continue growing. We definitely don't want to be there.
Alright! That's it.
Production and costs (not all) are in the books.
We look at the margin/average relationship ...
next. Hope you've enjoyed it!